good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight we have news for you
breaking news that for whatever reason
is being downplayed or ignored by other
media outlets but we think you want to
know about it five simple words describe
it
there was no Russian collusion there's
no evidence whatsoever that the Trump
campaign conspired in any way with the
government of Vladimir Putin during the
last presidential election period that's
apparently the conclusion of the
bipartisan Senate Intelligence Committee
that committee spent two years
investigating this question of course
hundreds of interviews reams of
classified documents untold millions in
taxpayer dollars no collusion at all
that is what we are hearing tonight they
have found now if you've been following
a story at all and of course you have
been you will not be surprised by this
no Russian collusion is a lot like moon
landing actually happened or a Bominable
snowman was probably a long-haired
mountain goat you knew that already
because you're not an idiot but if so
compare your mental acuity to that of
prominent political figures here in
Washington next time you feel dumb watch
this tape I think there's plenty of
evidence of collusion or conspiracy in
plain sight Trump has the Kremlin clan
surrounding him there's more to be
learned about it I believe there's been
collusion it's starting to smell more
and more like collusion we saw cold hard
evidence of the Trump campaign indeed
the Trump family eagerly intending to
collude possibly with Russia hard
evidence of collusion in the end it was
all fake and they knew that they knew it
wasn't real they were lying from the
very first day only their remarkable
aggression their willingness to say
literally anything no matter how
outrageous or slanderous or vile kept
the rest of us from catching on to what
they were doing if the chairman of the
House Intelligence Committee is willing
to call someone
to this country there's got to be some
truth to it right actually no there
wasn't it was always a hoax Adam Schiff
as an unscrupulous charlatan that's the
real lesson here don't expect people
like Schiff to apologize though or
correct the record much less repair the
lives of the people they have destroyed
Carter page still can't find a job Roger
stone is still facing life in prison
meanwhile ship's PR team on the other
channel continues like none of this ever
happened
here's Malcolm Nance of MSNBC explains
the results of a two-year Senate
investigation mean nothing people are
guilty because we say they're guilty we
must punish them let me just say one
thing when Benedict Arnold gave the
plans to West Point to major Andre and
they captured major Andre they did not
have any real information linking those
plans to Benedict Arnold other than the
fact that he was in his presence at one
point during that day but everyone knew
it was treason when they caught the man
and they hung him so at some point there
was going to be a bridge of data here
that is going to be unassailable no one
had any evidence but everyone knew it
was treason when they caught the man and
they hung him that says it all
let's repeat that once again slowly she
can write down those words and put them
on your fridge as a memento of the
terrifying mass hysteria we've all just
lived through quote everyone knew it was
treason when they caught the man and
they hung him that's our country now
that's what the Russia and sanity has
done to us the real government shutdown
has lasted for nearly two and a half
years that's 1% of this country's entire
existence we no longer have meaningful
policy debates in Washington we have
investigations instead nobody can think
clearly everybody's afraid the country's
core problems don't even rate as
interesting anymore either to
legislators or the TV pundits who
comment on legislators the suicide rate
just here 50-year high did you know that
we're in the middle of the worst drug
epidemic in the history of America
including the one after the civil war in
the heroin epidemic of the 70s and the
crack epidemic of the eighties this is
way worse and it's
one of the reasons the life expectancy
in many parts of the country is dropping
this is starting to look like Boris
Yeltsin's Russia and yet nobody in
Washington even notices all Adam Schiff
and the rest of the wild-eyed morons can
think about is Vladimir Putin collusion
or hacked democracy and all the other
mindless slogans they've repeated long
enough to half believe we've spent two
years perpetuating a fraud and they are
still doing it what is this it's
negligence on a stunning scale there's
nothing to do with Trump it is
everything to do with running this
country and they're not historians will
look back on this moment in amazement
and in sadness who put these crackpots
in charge and let them break things why
didn't any responsible person in the
media say anything about it why did they
collude in the charade what the hell
happened to America history will judge
us for this moment Adams just grandkids
will be ashamed of what he did